pinterest does my first job after
college and then i did
just a software engineer on the growth
team and then after that
i started a company that was uh acquired
by credit karma through that time while
i was thinking of different ideas and
ideating as
listening to you regularly so thanks for
that yeah it's really interesting
because i have these conversations with
people
on the show and then i meet them in
person and
they act incredibly friendly to me and
i'm like
because i already feel like we have a
rapport and we're talking a little bit
and shooting the [ __ ] before the show
started
and i realized what it is i've been in
people's ears for a decade
or five years on 2x
and then you meet me in person and we
start having these conversations oh yeah
for some people this is their 200th hour
of having a conversation
with me or being in a conversation
because you're hearing me and another
founder
and now it's a chance for people in high
school to hear you on the program
and be inspired when did you first hear
about non-fungible tokens
and this concept and what happened in
your brain
when you saw it so 20 late 2017 which is
really when
this whole space began i was deep into
crypto i was
pretty set on doing something in the
crypto space it was just a matter of
what whether that was joining a company
starting a company but i was going to
all the meetups back when you could
actually go to physical learning as much
as i could about it
and then this project cryptokitties
which i believe you had on the show
dapper labs
hit the mainstream tech scene and
really showed the world that there was
other stuff to do in crypto outside of
pure financial or pure
tech plays but that this could be a more
consumer
mainstream audience type of technology
so that's when that's when the world
heard of non-fungible tokens and that's
when i
got interested in it so yeah a while
back now
and what was your idea you saw it
happening you crypto kitties
and you see this happening in a very
open way you must have had some aha
moment
to create your platform was your
original idea to
create non-fungible tokens or to create
a marketplace what was your
original idea pretty much the original
idea was to create a marketplace
there was a moment when we were doing a
completely different idea in crypto
around sharing
wi-fi using cryptocurrency but we
quickly pivoted from that
and then there was a small moment where
we just wanted to build a game on top of
cryptokitties so one of the cool things
about
cryptokitties was because you owned them
on the blockchain
you could go and build developers could
build experiences that use your
cryptokitties but in
different creative ways so someone built
like a kitty hats
application where you could accessorize
your cryptokitties and then this other
team
built a kitty racing thing and they were
all very early
experiments but that kind of led us to
this idea you can
have these things outside of the
original application that they were born
in and so that maybe you could build
a marketplace that allows you to trade
all this stuff that exists
outside of the game or the project and
that was the aha moment where we're like
okay
that's a cool new novel concept and then
let's go and try
and see if we can take it to market and
of course it was such an early market
that we had to
patiently grow with the space as new nft
started
coming online so it feels to me very
much like the early days
of the world wide web where you got your
internet connection and then maybe you
had your email
or you were in usenet news groups and
you had a news reader
and then rss came and you had web
browsers all these like
desperate pieces in the experience it
feels that way a little bit right now in
crypto
you have people who let you mint nfts
to create one and then you have
marketplaces like yours and then you
have
roham's platform and what he's doing a
dapper and then also topshop
how does this all fit together do all
the tokens allow you to be traded
anywhere so
nobody has a lock on the assets that's
right i would say that
inventory of the assets the beautiful
thing about it is that the inventory is
shared right so you can
create an item on some art platform but
then you can actually go
and it's in your wallet and you own it
so you can go and take it to openc and
resell it so some of our
some of the marketplaces that are more
oriented towards people will actually
go and flip those on open seat or
something like that and then
gaming it's similar we haven't seen as
you said it's early days
but there's this cool idea where you
could take an item from one game and
actually bring it into another
game pretty seamlessly because again
it's all connected to your wallet
and so users have the freedom to kind of
do whatever they want with these things
and developers can really easily once
they get over the hump of
learning how blockchains work which is
of course an area of development
they can like integrate these things
yeah there's less of a sort of
data mode around the nfts themselves the
nfts that are minted
through our platform for example aren't
proprietary to openc
they just happen to be created there
because it's a very yeah
this was a very interesting concept
because in fact cryptocurrency
people the sort of dry run of
cryptocurrency was
mana and gold in games specifically
massively multiplayer online games
and people forget this but brock pierce
who was
big into cryptocurrency now he had
started a company called the internet
gaming company
or internet gaming entertainment with
steve bannon i believe
the the trump's organizer and what their
concept was hey people are playing world
of warcraft or whatever
we'll go into the game itself as a
character
take your plus 27 sword that's worth 800
that you spent a year building up your
character or your sword or whatever you
found
and then we'll go give it to somebody
else but we'll make sure
on our website you have bought that item
which was completely against everybody's
terms of service etc and
i think they did it out of china if i
remember correctly there was some way
they were
getting around this currency selling and
it was explained that those were like
miles for they weren't currency because
they were like
airline miles they didn't really have an
equivalent and then of course
mark pincus did zynga and he had zynga
coins etc so that was all this kind of
interesting dry run
but is anybody doing that yet where in a
in one game fortnite
you could take an asset put it on the
blockchain and trade it has that
even come to pass yet a little bit so i
would say that the most promising
experiences there
are so there's all this digital art out
there right there's like
people minting this expensive crypto art
there's even some traditional artists
starting to mint just pure digital art
and there's these virtual world projects
one is called the central land another
one is called crypto voxels
and these virtual world projects let you
bring that digital art in
and make museums of it so this first
instance right where you can you have
this equivalent of a physical
environment
to display your digital stuff and
suddenly it's like
that digital stuff starts feeling a lot
more real because you can take it with
you to these different places
so gaming there's been a few experiments
i think you could bring your
cryptokitties into this
trading card game like early stuff but i
think the there's this really
interesting symbiosis with the digital
art world and these virtual worlds
that's going on and that's where a lot
of the kind of early activities
happening it's not happening from like
the more mainstream established games
it's more
early startups that are more
experimental
how much time and money do you spend
integrating a bunch of different
software products together at your
company
let me guess way too much time oh do is
here to help
odoo is a suite of business apps that
runs your entire company
on one platform they'll streamline your
workflow by bringing all of that
information together
plus odoo's integrations eliminate
repetitive tasks and data entry
if you only need two or three apps to
optimize your workflow
that's all you pay for odoo won't stick
you with the bill for apps you don't use
odoo has an app for every business need
they offer 30 main apps
that are updated regularly in over 16
000 apps
from their active open source community
you can keep your books tight with their
financial software
and their sales and crm apps will help
provide a clear and organized view of
your business
so here is your call to action your
first app is free forever
and right now odoo is offering a 1 000
credit on your first implementation pack
that's not a joke that's a thousand
dollars just go to
odoo.com twist to check it out that's
odo.com twist